i think you've tweeted that uh you
believe that bitcoin has a chance of uh
reaching one million i don't know what
it is currently i think it's five
sixties which is incredible
i think i remember when it was at least
in the double digits i think i remember
was in the signal digit of a dollar
so the fact that it's across 50 is crazy
uh but uh you're even crazier apparently
thinking that it can reach a million
so do you think it's possible for it to
reach a million is there some kind of
transformative effects we'll have to see
first
when might it reach a million like what
are the signs that we would look for
what's required for it to reach a
million so let's just look at it from a
macro perspective
uh gold is a 10 trillion dollar asset
and when you compare the technology of
gold
to the technology of bitcoin bitcoin is
superior in every single way
right it's more portable it's more
divisible it's more verifiable it's more
scarce on
everything and so some people would
argue it's a 10x improvement some people
argue it's 100x improvement from a
technology standpoint
and so we don't need bitcoin to actually
kind of um capture the full 10x or 100x
improvement from a market cap standpoint
if bitcoin simply captures 2x the value
would be a 20 trillion dollar market cap
which would put bitcoin at about a
million dollars
right so kind of just from a macro
perspective if you have a 10x or 100x
improvement from a technology standpoint
and you directionally get some value
capture in that direction
you're hitting around a million or more
uh dollar price point
you can ask a quick question which is uh
what's the current market cap for
bitcoin
uh the current market cap's right around
a trillion just over a trillion dollars
and he's saying gold is 10 trillion
and uh sorry where did you get the 20
trillion
20 trillion would just be 2x gold's
market cap got it right so if it's a 10x
technology improvement let's just say it
only captures 2x the market cap got it
right
and so again if it was to capture just
gold's market cap kind of the equivalent
puts you around 500 thousand dollars
right so you can kind of see there's a
bitcoin
so if you capture the entirety of the
gold market
uh then it will be value of a single
bitcoin uh the price of a single bitcoin
would be
500 000
okay to reach a million it would be
double that
that's what the 20 trillion comes from
correct got it so if you then
say to yourself okay how does the uh
the pricing um kind of cycles work right
or the boom and bust cycles
gold is a very um kind of linear
type supply schedule meaning that
there is a certain amount of gold that
comes out of the ground each year the
inter-year variation in that incoming
supply
is not much right maybe there's an extra
mining company that gets set up or a
couple of them
or maybe one goes out of business but
for the most part the kind of
inflationary
uh increase to the supply of gold
is pretty stagnant uh year over year
bitcoin has
a very unique feature which every four
years there is a programmatic supply
shock meaning that uh in the beginning
50 bitcoin every 10 minutes was
introduced into the supply
after four years of that happening every
10 minutes it was cut in half
so on a single moment it went from 50 to
now it was 25
4 years every 10 minutes 25 got cut in
half again to 12 and a half and then
recently in may 2020 got cut to 6.25
when you have an asset that is
determined the price
based on supply and demand you normally
have two inputs to the equation
what is the supply and what is the
demand in an asset like gold
or a stock or anything else we have to
do our best
guess at the supply both the existing
supply and the incoming supply
and do our best guess at the demand and
we're actually pretty good at this a lot
of times in terms of directionally
saying it's going to go up or down and
here's kind of some price point
milestones
bitcoin's unique in that there's 100
verifiable
proof of the existing supply
the total supply and the incoming daily
supply
so we know 100 i can show you on the
actual blockchain
or in the code that there's 21 million
bitcoin uh and that's all there will
ever be
i can show you that there's 18.6 million
give or take
uh bitcoin that actually are in
circulation today right and i can go all
the way back to every single transaction
that's ever occurred since january
through 2009
and then i can show you on a daily basis
that 900 bitcoin a day are coming into
the circulating supply
and so when you have 100 confidence
because you can prove
the supply side of this equation you can
hold it constant
i know with 100 accuracy the supply side
so now i've reduced the mathematical
equation that i need to do to determine
price movements
to a 50 reduction i only have to worry
about demand i don't have to worry about
supply
and so when i look at demand i can do
all kinds of things i can take the
demand over the last 10 years and the
growth and just extrapolate it out i can
increase it i can decrease it whatever
but what you find is that these supply
shocks
lead to significant price appreciation
as the asset gets repriced because there
there's a supply shock to it
and so probably the best thing that i've
done over the last couple of years
was in 2019 i started to talk about the
idea that we were going to have both a
supply shock
and the demand shock in 2021
or i'm sorry in 2020. i didn't know when
this bull market that we were in was
gonna nobody knows right it's impossible
to time
these things but you could tell that we
were kind of at late stages of a cycle
there was inverted yield curves there
was re uh gyrations in the repo markets
a lot of ceos leaving their jobs you
know all this kind of stuff
and all i said was at some point when
the market turns over
the government's gonna have to step in
we were addicted to stimulus they're
going to have to manipulate interest
rates down and they're going to print
money
i had no clue that there was going to be
a global pandemic
that they were going to have to step in
in such an aggressive way and move rates
not down but down to zero
and that they not only were going to
print hundreds of billions but they
could print trillions of dollars
but the framework that i used to think
about this was when they do that
everyone is going to run to store value
assets they're going to run to gold
they're going to run the bitcoin et
cetera
and right as they do that it appears at
the same time there's going to be this
supply shock so you're going to get a
supply shock and a demand shock that are
both positive for the price and i call
it rocket fuel for bitcoin
well it happened and here we are i now
look forward and i say okay
we are likely going to see hundred
thousand bitcoin a hundred thousand
dollar bitcoin this year right at some
point i don't know when it happens but
we're moving in that's
what i think in 2021 we'll see a hundred
thousand
that would be uh my most conservative
view uh i
i've said a hundred thousand dollars
since 2019 and people thought that was
insane and crazy and all stuff now i'm
the conservative guy in the room because
i stick with the hundred thousand
dollars and people are saying
you know multiples of that number uh so
we'll see what happens but
but i think that there's still a lot of
room kind of to run from a u.s dollar
price standpoint
what is on the horizon is in 2024 we
will have another supply shock
and so that's what i think will carry us
to the million dollar bitcoin from 625
to whatever
50 reduction yeah yeah and so that's
what i think
uh we'll basically when we get that that
next supply shock that'll carry us up
over 100
or over a 1 million dollar bitcoin price
which
if historical examples persist and again
sometimes it's hard to use historical
examples to uh look at future
events um but if that happens we would
see a million dollars of bitcoin by the
end of 2026.
after that wave so 2024 basically is the
supply shock and within
you know 18 to 24 months you would see
the uh
the kind of top of the next market
hopefully without a coupling to the net
to another pandemic yes we we would like
to do all of this without a
public health crisis so that would take
it to
would uh 20 trillion you don't have to
compare to the dollar
essentially in some sense that the
dollar could also lose value i mean
there's a lot of kind of dynamics at
play here
now but like fundamentally there's going
to be a huge
move in your prediction of value into
into bitcoin
you